salut
juin 2010 neuf aéroports
montréal-trudeau sindia gagner et judith
car on se rencontre pour la première
fois pourtant s apprête à vivre ensemble
une expérience des plus intimes stressé
mais
je suis me sens comme presque libérée et
toi juste dit je contente de la saint
louis
parce que je souffrais la nuit est
incroyablement elles s'en vont à saint
loup au missouri pour cacher rue regel
retire un dispositif médical qui leur
empoisonne la vie
combien ça va vous coûter dalle élabore
l'argent canadien cynthia 23500
d'horreur exactement là où un coup tout
terminé et vous judith ça me manque un
peu près 18 mai comme une trentaine de
québécoises depuis quelques mois
cynthia gagner et judith caron ont
choisi de dépenser beaucoup d'argent aux
états unis plutôt que de se faire opérer
au québec
j'ai décidé à saint-louis parce que je
veux ressentir sur mes deux jambes puis
je veux vraiment être capable de revivre
ma vie les femmes que nous avons
rencontrées vivent une crise de
confiance envers ce qui pourrait les
opérer au québec
nous allons tenter de comprendre
pourquoi pour mais bonne chance pour vos
opérations se parle après la chirurgie
qui est d'1 3 jours
[Musique]
j'ai mal géré dans les n 1 go d'hubert 5
des hanches
en fait je me sens comme une femme de 66
ans nous avons fait un premier reportage
sur l'histoire de cynthia gagné en mars
2019 comme des milliers de canadiennes
chaque année en 2015
la jeune femme s'était fait implanter
une bandelette de plastique sous
l'urètre pour traiter un problème
d'incontinence à l'effort
on lui avait dit que ce dispositif
médical faisait des miracles sans lui
dire que chez 10% des femmes environ
il entraînait des complications des
complications parfois dramatiques mon
combo c'est de trouver quelqu'un qui va
m'enlever cette bande est l'eau
le problème c'est que les bandelettes ne
sont pas conçus pour être enlevé très
rapidement elle se greffe aux tissus aux
muscles et parfois au zoo en conséquence
la plupart des médecins sont formés pour
les poser mais pas pour les enlever et
quand les problèmes surviennent il n'y a
pas de consensus médical sur la façon de
les régler en un push sait plus à qui
faire confiance
nous avions sa compagne et cynthia chez
plusieurs urologue québécois qui lui
avait offert des traitements différents
injection de cortisone retrait partiel
de la bandelette ou retrait complet une
chirurgie invasive et risque est
proposée par une urologue qui disait en
avoir fait quelques unes seulement
j'angoisse un petit peu à savoir ce que
est ce que c'est ce que je vais prendre
la bonne décision
nous avions aussi accompagné cynthia à
saint louis au missouri où pratiquer le
docteur dionisio ce véronique s à
nouveau gynécologue spécialisée dans
leurs traites bandelettes
il m'assure que je dois absolument
élever la bande est au complet et ne
parlant que partiellement au printemps
dernier cynthia gagner ne se doutait pas
de longues de choc que notre reportage
allait provoquer elle venait tout juste
de fonder un groupe de soutien sur
facebook en quelques jours j'ai été
bombardé de 400 messages en attente
personnel j'ai eu des téléphones à la
maison pour des gens chercher de l'aide
six semaines après la diffusion nous
avons retrouvé cynthia gagner à ottawa
elle était accompagnée de sept membres
de son groupe de soutien
qu'est ce qui te le plus frappé depuis
la diffusion de l'émission
en fait c'est la douleur des femmes
c'est la ressemblance de nos symptômes
des femmes douleur qui sent tout seul
chacun de leur côté
on voit des histoires vraiment m'excuser
dorin
des médecins qui savent pas vraiment
quoi faire avec les patients dans
quelques minutes les huit femmes ont
rendez vous avec des représentants de
santé canada on est ici aujourd'hui pour
vraiment représenter la situation la
problématique des bancs des deux
continents
on va aussi leur démontrer que les
médecins et son environnement dans le
déni ce fait à nos déclarations les
femmes se font dire que leur douleur en
pot rapport avec leur avec leur
bandelettes
on ne nous a pas permis d'assister aux
témoignages des femmes
mais quelques semaines plus tard
certaines d'entre elles sont venues nous
raconter leur histoire en compagnie
d'autres femmes
[Musique]
tous les matins moi je pleurais le peux
je m'éclate épaules mais ça coulait le
sait les gens du rpt et ma douleur
ça faisait mal se faisait très mal mais
ça faisait comme s'ils comprenaient des
lames de couteaux d'un gène puis au
dessus des zones où ce que la viande et
été installés mab angleterre et
reversements lurette
ça avait fait des pierres de la
qualification au tour puis ce succès
effecté sous marche mais sa satire d'un
côté alors scellé les bourses elles se
développent les tendinites les médecins
disent que les complications sont rares
pourtant dans le groupe facebook de
cynthia il y a près de 600 femmes qui se
disent blessés par leur bandelettes 365
d'entre elles ont répondu à un sondage
maison qui met en lumière les symptômes
les plus fréquents douleur lors de
relations sexuelles
48 % des répondantes difficultés à
marcher 46% difficultés à rester assise
longtemps 42% douleurs chroniques au zen
35% douleur chronique ou 1 h 33 %
infections urinaires à répétition 32%
la plupart de ces complications
potentielles sont répertoriés dans les
brochures des fabricants de bandelettes
et dans des avis publiés par santé
canada
pourtant beaucoup de femmes affirment
sur le groupe facebook que les médecins
ne les reconnaissent pas lorsqu'elle se
présente
moi j'ai passé des irm des crises de
saint yon tout analysé arthrose arthrite
j'avais rencontré mon neurologue en
janvier avant l'émission
puis il m'a fait des tests p10 la
bandelette ya aucun rapport des douleurs
mécanique sa part rapport avec la bande
lettre je dis arrêtez vos deux examens
le chemin ici pour trouver des solutions
parce que ma douleur la bandelette je le
suis c'est ça après avoir vu notre
premier reportage sans même consulter ou
tenir compte de l'avis de ruraux log
toutes ces femmes ont décidé de se faire
retirer leur bandelettes complètement
elle devait choisir entre des urologues
québécois qui ont fait peu le retrait
complet et lure au gynécologue américain
dionisio ce véronique et qui dit en
avoir fait autour de 800 je voyais pas
comment quelqu'un que fait quelques
opérations d'enlèvement demande l'aide
pouvait compétitionner avec doc taverny
qui selon moi c'était il y avait aucune
chance à prendre
il était hors de question que je le
fasse rare au québec
elles ont été les 6 premières patientes
québécoise du docteur véronique hills
elle ne doutait pas de la compétence des
urologues québécois mais elle ne se
sentait pas rassurés par le fait qu'il
semblait avoir fait peu de retrait
complet un peu stressant et dans une
ville du sud déjà prêt l'opération dans
un hôtel de saint louis
cynthia boucle sa valise pour se rendre
à l'hôpital dans 25 second tour
bayon des nouvelles bientôt comment ça
s'est passé
ce n'était pas une bonne place et
difficile à retrouver pour une session
de matraques
il était encore trop tôt pour savoir si
la chirurgie allait définitivement
libéré cynthia de ses douleurs mais déjà
elle était convaincue que les milliers
de dollars qu elle venait de verser au
docteur véronique était un bon
investissement
il a fait l'impossible et on le vus de
la bandelette j'ai vu des bandes être
retirée si au québec
cette photo qui a beaucoup circulé dans
le groupe de cynthia at elle raison de
faire peur aux québécois
[Musique]
la rame je dois reconnaître que pour le
moment il n'y a aucun chirurgien qui
possède l'expérience nécessaire pour
retirer complètement des bandelettes qui
cause des douleurs
cette déclaration est la revendication
principale de cynthia gagner celle ci ne
remet pas en question la compétence des
urologues québécois elles demandent que
leur manque d'expérience en matière de
retrait complet de bandelettes soit
reconnue le 27 octobre dernier 82
membres de son groupe de soutien étaient
réunis dans un hôtel de trois rivières
elle arborait fièrement leurs mots clics
amaechi à mai chez comme dans mèche le
nom anglais qu'on donne aux bandelettes
présentement en cours afin de rembourser
nos chirurgie aux états unis à ce jour
trente et une québécoise sont allés
faire retirer leur bandelettes aux états
unis pour justifier son refus de
rembourser les frais du type de
chirurgie qu'elles ont subi la régie
d'assurance maladie dû québec invoque
que quelques médecins québécois sont
capables d'en faire des semblables
nous nous sommes intéressés à l'histoire
de deux femmes qui se sont fait retirer
leur bandelettes au québec dès la sortie
de l'opération j'avais une douleur
intense comme j'avais jamais eu
j'avais jamais subi une douleur comme ça
dans ma vie lisse brouillard s'est fait
poser une bandelette en 2017
six semaines plus tard elle a toujours
mal lorsqu elle revoit son neurologue
primo référer à un neurologue
j'ai passé des tests en urologie on
disait que tout était correct je veux
ostéopathe j'ai fait de la
physiothérapie de l'acupuncture un
neurologue un orthopédiste médecins en
médecine sportive
jamais personne jeudi c'est votre
pamphlet peut-être personne jamais sept
mois après la chirurgie elle n'en peut
plus elle retourne voir son urologue le
jouer tu en faisais moi ça c'est la
seule chose que j'ai pas essayé renversé
ça pour voir ce que ça va donner son
urologue la réfère à un neurologue de
l'hôpital général juif de montréal
dis moi dis la marche a transpercé le le
mot vaginale faut opérer et ça presse
la bandelette c'est aussi collé sur un
air ce qui cause probablement la douleur
dans la jambe gauche
l'urologue propose d'enlever la
bandelette complètement
c'est ce que j'en comprends la chirurgie
soulage la douleur intense mais un
inconfort persiste
madame brouillard retourne voir
l'urologue est une
et que la neige était complètement
enlevé restait moins de 20 cm et que
dans aucun temps ce que ce système moins
d'un centimètre là qu'ils pouvaient
causer les problèmes mesures autour
d'eux qu'ils lisent brouillard a des
doutes
elles demandent son dossier médical sur
leur apparence montre qu' aux cinq
centimètres de la bandelette qui a été
retiré sur une bandelette comme dit
qu'ils devraient avoir aucun sens mais
madame brouillard se dit qu'elle a sans
doute mal compris
elle reprend rendez-vous et enregistre
la consultation
il faut arrêter de délirer je vous
garantis que c'est pas la mèche il reste
1 cm du côté droit
ce côté gauche il n'y absolument plus
rien
quand madame brouillard dit à l'urologue
qui lui semble avoir lu dans son rapport
de pathologies que 5 cm de bandelettes
seulement avaient été retirés
il répond qu'il n'a pas le rapport sous
les yeux que ça devrait être beaucoup
plus que ça et il réitère que presque
toute la bandelette a été enlevé ce qui
reste c'est vraiment le petit centimètre
qui traverse le trou obturateur pour ce
qui reste de la mèche
n'y pensez plus j'ai décidé d'aller voir
à saint louis
un docteur vernet pièces et de me faire
opérer madame brouillard n'est pas au
bout de ses surprises
ginette et aurait aussi a eu des
problèmes
immédiatement après la pause de sa
bandelette deux que je suis allé au
rendez vous de suivi
j'avais d'un sculpteur ma60 comme un
ballon dans mon ventre un grand
inconfort comme si quelque chose coince
à l'urologue de madame théorêt la réfère
à une urologue de l'hôpital maisonneuve
rosemont a le tout de suite fait un
examen gynécologique
puis alors constaté que a touché la
bande du bout de ses doigts
la bandelette à perforer la paroi
vaginale l'urologue propose un retrait
partiel de quelques centimètres en me
réveillant j'avais les mains mind ou
leur apport que j'avais plus mon ballon
mais toutes mes douleurs aux jambes
alem c'était la même chose l'urologue
suggère d'opérer à nouveau pour enlever
les quelques 20 cm de bandelettes qui
reste sa très peu près deux semaines
pour que les douleurs reviennent donc
que je me rende compte que j'avais
encore les douleurs aux jambes a montré
la photo pg 6
c'était plus cher quand vous avez vu la
photo de la bandelette de cimetière
comment vous avez réagi j'ai pleuré
c'est pas comparer l à l'eau
tu vois tout la bandelette intacte mois
on la voit pas du tout c'est une simple
des chars convoi le pire c'est que la
saga n'est pas terminée
un petit bout de bandelettes laisser en
place vient de perforer à nouveau la
paroi vaginale de madame théorêt
urologue propose de ne pas tenter un
troisième retrait pour le moment
elle prescrit un traitement de cortisone
un irm et un suivi un mois plus tard moi
j'ai l'impression que je suis déjà dans
le fond un condamné je sais pas si
une autre intervention va pas régler mon
problème qu'en est il des québécoises
qui ont opté pour un retrait aux états
unis en octobre au rassemblement des as
mais chez nous avons croisé certaines
d'entre elles
li na a perdu de la force dans une jambe
à cause de la chirurgie de retrait et se
fit luce a encore des douleurs dans les
jambes mais les trois femmes ont
retrouvé leur bien-être qui louent leurs
mécaniques sont disparus je viens rien
de ça ça va se parer de lure est perforé
donc
de ce côté là tout à bing et riz aucun
problème ça pour ça vient c'est la
libération tata jousten s'affiche à
melbourne regretté golfe
sophie lucet annabelle ont demandé à la
ramq eu de rembourser les frais de leur
chirurgie la ramq eu à refuser en
rappelant entre autres que des médecins
québécois sont capables de faire la
chirurgie sur la courte liste selon nos
sources le roll up qui a opéré lise
brouillard le colloque qui a opéré
ginette théorêt est une autre rowluck
réputé du centre hospitalier
universitaire de sherbrooke le chu ce
trois médecins en qui beaucoup de femmes
ont perdu confiance
à cause de ce qui circule sur le groupe
facebook
dans le cas de l'urologue du chuss elle
affirme avoir fait peu de retrait
complet et dans des enregistrements de
consultation que nous ont fait parvenir
deux patientes
elle déclare que les bandelettes retirer
complètement mesure de 11 à 13 cm
cette information fait craindre aux
femmes que cet urologue ne fait pas de
véritable retrait complet 11 à 13 cm
c'est beaucoup plus court que les
bandelettes retiré par les trois experts
que nous avons consultés nous avons
obtenu les rapports de pathologie des 30
québécoises qui sont allés à saint louis
la longueur moyenne de leurs bandelettes
de type t'es ôter les bandelettes les
plus courtes était de 20 cm
pour se plier de l'urologue de l'hôpital
maisonneuve rosemont
cette photo de la bandelette qu'elle a
retiré à ginette théorêt a fait grimper
l'appréhension sur le groupe facebook
nous avons consulté un expert français
pour savoir si les femmes avaient raison
d'avoir peur lorsque j'ai vu lille à
l'image j'ai pas été particulièrement
impressionné par là l'importance des
tissus et des chairs qui était au
contact de la bandelette docteur xavier
gamme et urologue nous a été présenté
comme l'un des experts français du
retrait de bandelettes
c'est pas parce qu'il ya la chair autour
de la bandelette que forcément ça va
avoir des conséquences et des cycles
pour le docteur gamme et cette photo n'a
dit qu part que le retrait a fait du
tort à madame t aurais je pense pas en
francs réalité je pense que initialement
surtout s'il avait des douleurs à type
de brûlures d'échauffement d'emblée
après la prise en a mis en place de la
bandelette ça c'est tout à fait
évocateur en fait de lésions neurogel
donc dans ce cas là ça peut être la
pause qui a créé les douleurs
persistantes exactement
pour ce qui est de l'urologue de
l'hôpital général juif
c'est lui qui avait affirmé alice
brouillard qu'il ne lui restait qu'un
centimètre de bandelettes
il y a trois mois madame brouillard
s'est fait opéré par le docteur
véronique et leur lot de madame
brouillard avait laissé sept centimètres
de bandelettes à gauche et 10 cm à
droite
il est important d'être formés au
retrait d'une part et d'en faire
régulièrement pour voir le faire
justement correctement et complètement
parce que quelqu'un qui en fait une fois
de temps en temps ne va pas forcément
avoir l'habitude et être capable
d'enlever de la bandelette dans sa
globalité
si les urologues québécois ont moins
d'expérience en matière de retrait
complet
c'est en partie parce qu'il privilégie
le retrait partiel qui peut être
indiquée dans certains cas l'urologue de
lys brouillard n'a pas donné suite à nos
demandes d'entrevue
l'urologue du chuss et celle de madame
théorêt ont décliné même chose pour
l'association des urologues du québec
dans une lettre elle déclare à propos de
la pose de bandelettes que ses membres
vivent quotidiennement les succès de
cette chirurgie qui transforme
positivement la vie de patientes
incontinentes elle ajoute qu une
excision partiel peut s'avérer
nécessaire et que celle ci est pratiqué
par plusieurs urologue dans les cas
beaucoup plus rare nécessitant une
excision complète les patientes n'ont
pas besoin d'aller ailleurs que ce type
de chirurgie a été réalisée avec succès
au québec
nous avons soumis l'ensemble de notre
dossier au collège des médecins
on est très préoccupée par des femmes
qui souffrent présentement il faut faire
quelque chose
le collège a décidé de déclencher une
enquête il va faire une recherche de
fonds sur le sujet rencontrer des
experts et des patientes étudier les
dossiers médicaux de patientes et
interroger leur chirurgien docteur
robert demande un peu de patience aux
femmes
la seule chose si on peut par une
nouveau problème immédiatement on va
trouver une solution d'aveux proche
avenir
c'est ce que je souhaite c'est ça
d'enfance avons travaillé le travail d'
enquête devrait aboutir à des
recommandations et des normes de
pratique pour la question c est y
aurait-il mieux par exemple de
concentrer dans une seule équipe qui en
fait plus les soins de sève de cette
nature là qui existent je ne
technique en attendant les résultats de
l'enquêté
le collège étudie la possibilité
d'intervenir auprès de la ram cul pour
qu'elle reconsidère son refus de
rembourser tous les retraits complet
fait aux états unis on peut faire
certainement une suggestion une
recommandation l'a vaincu mais il va
falloir vraisemblablement que le
gouvernement autorise ce paiement auprès
de la sec pour intervenir exact la
ministre de la santé daniel mais cannes
nous a écrit qu'elle allait laisser le
collège mener ses travaux et faire ses
recommandations à la régie de
l'assurance maladie du québec
avant d'intervenir à ce jour le
gouvernement de l'ontario à rembourser
les frais de chirurgie aux états unis
d'au moins une quinzaine de patients il
y a quelques semaines
la première ministre de l'écossé a
ordonné une enquête sur le retrait de
bandelettes quand il a été révélé que
trois écossaise avait vécu des histoires
similaires à celles de lise brouillard
la première ministre du pays a
personnellement invité le docteur
véronique skis à réopéré ces trois
femmes à venir faire un séjour en écosse
pour faire des opérations et former les
chirurgiens écossais nous avons revu
cynthia gagner tout récemment ce n'était
plus la femme souffrante que nous avions
connu il y a eu heureusement un petit
polar à la hanche que ça va vraiment
bien j'ai recommencé à bouger à part du
pardo vraiment bien
honnêtement j'ai même monter les deux
montagnes dans les dernières semaines je
suis vraiment content
[Musique]
on
je
[Musique]